and i'm gonna be completely honest with
you i went to the doctor
and i was like all right i'm just gonna
get a checkup see what's going on
the honest truth is i knew it wasn't
gonna be awesome
okay i knew the doctor wasn't gonna be
like uh
you might be surprised to hear this but
you're perfect like
you're a perfect physical specimen man
i knew that wasn't going to happen but i
didn't expect him to be a dick
usually they're not i feel like in my
experience doctors are polite almost
overly polite where it's phony
and condescending when they go oh
really interesting story you got there
doctors do that because you're telling
them a story
and doctors don't want to hear a story
doctors want to hear this hurts
not i was over at my friend charlie's
house and we went to move the ottoman
and i mean you can use it as a coffee
table or you could use it as an ottoman
it's up to you
and your doctor's like i want to blow my
[ __ ] brains out right now
i go in there i sit on the exam table
which is my least favorite table to sit
on in the world
this is the only table that in 30 years
i've sat on where my feet don't touch
the ground
so i feel like a [ __ ] toddler waiting
like
my doctor comes in he doesn't say hello
he doesn't say good morning he just
walks in he points at me
which is super aggressive you know to
start a conversation with somebody like
hey man you're like hey what's up man
and he goes do you want something for
your hair and i go
what
and he goes do you want something for
your hair
and i go i don't get it
and he goes says nobody told you that
your hair's falling out
and i was like damn
no and he goes oh
sorry
all right then he pulls my chart out of
the slot
super dramatic so that it makes a
[ __ ] noise he goes
and he goes wow and i'm like really wow
is it full-blown aids like why is it wow
and he goes you weigh 245 and i go like
yeah like i knew that [ __ ] and he goes
you weigh 230
last time you were here not exactly what
i would call
weight loss i'm like are we in a [ __ ]
roast or something right like what are
you doing
then he says you know you're the fattest
patient i've seen
all day
and i go it's 9 30 in the morning
and he goes still
he's like you know we ran your blood
work it turns out your
muscle enzymes are through the roof and
i go
yeah man like i'm super strong like how
is that a problem
and he goes they're off the charts i'm
like even better
i'm probably your strongest patient man
and he goes i don't think you understand
muscle enzymes and i go that's true i
don't know what they are
and he goes well the only way you could
have them this high would be like
a if you were an olympic athlete which
clearly you know i'm like dude what is
the deal man
he goes the other way would be if you
were a cocaine addict
and i go i don't do coke and he goes i'm
your doctor you don't lie to me
like i'm not lying and he goes i can't
treat you you're not going to be honest
and i go hey man aren't cokeheads skinny
isn't that like part of the deal
and he goes usually yeah the nurse comes
in
she takes my chart out of his hands and
she goes oh my god
his muscle enzymes are so high
maybe he runs marathons and my doctor
goes look at him
so at this point i go this was a lot of
fun thank you for having me today
i'm going to leave now and he goes all
right and he goes ho hold on a second
you have a ring on your finger and i go
yeah and he goes
you're married and i go yeah
and he goes to a guy
and i go no and he goes ow i thought you
were gay
and i go why and he goes huh
like all right dude and he goes hey i'm
just kidding and i go that's fine he
goes but check it out
and he takes my chart and he shows it to
me and he had a written
gay question mark on my medical chart
the thing that gets sent to other
doctors
has his inside maybe he sucks [ __ ] joke
written on it
i went home i told my wife she's like oh
my god what are you gonna do
and i was like what do you mean she goes
i mean are you ever gonna go back there
i'm like are you out of your mind
that's the funniest [ __ ] doctor in
the world of course i'm going back there
i have like don rickles as my primary
care physician
it's amazing i'm faking injuries to go
back to this guy
you know you're a piece of [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] amazing